- [Conan] Now I wanna ask
you, Isaac, something.
You took a lot of anger.
A lot of people on Twitter
blamed you for Hodor's death.
(audience murmuring and laughing)
That's why I sat the two of you together.
(audience laughing)
I wanted a really awkward conversation.
How did you feel about that Twitter?
They got mad!
They were saying: "Hey,
that's your fault!"
- [Isaac] Yeah, I woke up to a torrent of:
"(beeping) you brands" and all sorts.
(audience laughing)
I had to say: "OK guys"--
- [Conan] Isaac, if you're
gonna talk that way,
you're not welcome here.
(audience laughing)
(laughing) I'm kidding.
Please, all the f-bombs you want.
- [Isaac] Oh my god. (chuckling)
- [Conan] Did you feel--
(laughing)
Christian, how did you interpret it?
Did you interpret it
that it was his fault?
- [Christian] Well--
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Conan] Any bitterness
towards Bran at all?
- [Christian] If you're
talking to me or Hodor,
it's two different things.
I am terribly bitter towards him,
but Hodor, I don't think Hodor blames you.
- [Audience] Aw!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Christian] I do, I do, I do.
(laughing)
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Conan] That's very nice.
Yes!
It's very sweet.